I have decided to take a big step back
from filming and really just pick and
choose what I will allow cameras to
follow Kourtney Kardashian famously
kinda-sorta quit Keeping Up with the
Kardashians back in April
Kourt you might leave this week she'll
be back they all come back and in a new
interview with vogue Arabia's July
August issue she's getting candid about
her decision to peace out saying that it
became a toxic environment I'm not
putting my energy there quote I have
been filming the show non-stop for 14
years I was feeling unfulfilled and it
became a toxic environment for me to
continue to have it occupy as much of my
life as it was I was anxious about
filming yes season it doesn't make me
happy like I don't want to miss out on
like time with my kids and like it's not
worth it the 41 year old reality star
added that she values her privacy and
when you're on a reality show finding
private moments is hard
I just I'm like I don't like being a
celebrity
well people have this misconception that
I don't want to work which isn't true I
am following my happiness and putting my
energy into that which makes me happy I
don't know I'm just like living life
yeah fans of the hit reality show know
that when Kourtney said people
she means her sisters Kim and Khloe who
went in on courts work ethic during
season 18 if I didn't want to work my
ass off and I wanted to be a
stay-at-home mom
that's been fine you can stay literal
and while court told the mag she's
grateful for the opportunities at the
show which premiered in 2007 gave her
she says that now spending time with her
kids is her main focus especially on
Saturday or Sunday quote we hang out at
the house and pajamas or sweats we sleep
in I like to not be on a schedule on
that day when et caught up with court
and her famous sisters last year before
she took a step back from keeping up she
admitted her focus was on the fan but
also said she's leaving the door open
for more Kardashian Khaos you mentioned
that you might be ready to say goodbye
to Keeping Up with the Kardashians where
are you at on that
I'm just decided to spend more time as a
mom and you know put more of my energy
there and still but I'm not saying
goodbye
[Music]